[Música]
aquí podemos observar
en esta siguiente imagen la mayor
expresión de amor que pude obtener en mi
vida mi familia
pero ojo no siempre fue así como en
todas las familias siempre hubieron
diferencias entre nosotros
el amor consiste en amar a todos los que
te rodean pero principalmente amarte a
ti mismo pero antes antes antes déjenme
hablarles sobre mi experiencia en el
amor
[Música]
soy el segundo hijo de un matrimonio
joven y apasionada con las emociones a
flote su intensidad en distintas
situaciones fue lo que caracterizó mi
hogar desde que tengo memoria considero
que también mis padres fueron mis
primeras influencias para adquirir este
amor por el arte por lado de mi mamá las
pinturas las artesanías y por lado de mi
papá
la música y la poesía
[Música]
recuerdo que mi tía contaba en una
reunión que no me gustaba cantar
canciones como mi mano izquierda
donde tu retrato y en mi otra mano una
copa de vino y brinca contigo sino estar
presente y brindé contigo por tu amor
ausente y me bebí tu recuerdo para que
jamás vuelva a lastimarme así fue como
todo comenzó según mi familia ahora lo
que yo puedo recordar es que desde niño
me gustaba mucho escuchar las canciones
que mi papá improvisaba y le dedica a mi
mamá y también a nosotros
[Música]
así fue que todo se fue intensificando
cada vez más hasta que primero se
convirtió en una pequeña visualización
posteriormente en un sueño y finalmente
en un enfoque musical eso es lo que me
encuentro realizando esa pequeña
visualización recuerdo que se dio cuando
estaba con mi hermano mayor
[Música]
nos imaginamos que estamos en un
concierto de escorpión está bueno yo me
estaba imaginando eso no
bueno estaba con él está por ahí
[Música]
en ese momento creo que fue cuando me
conecté con esta energía que ahora me
define y puedo transmitir a las personas
cada fin de semana en todos los
conciertos
iniciando mi adolescencia tuve el placer
de conocer a estos cuatro señores
mejores amigos y colegas musicales
señoras y señores con ustedes los emails
[Música]
out
[Aplausos]
efe
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a comienzos fue bastante difícil
engranar nos ya que cada uno sentía que
las cosas debían hacerse como cada quien
le parecía incluso decidir qué canciones
sacar era un poco complicado porque
también cada uno tenía gustos musicales
distintos
pero hubo algo que nos unió hubo un
fantástico común común denominador
[Música]
el rock and roll
[Aplausos]
guau
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el rock and roll el rockabilly
[Música]
aquí un número especial
y entran los bailarines
[Música]
bueno no sé si se recuerda en esta época
los corazones los tirantes
nos encantaba mucho esta época el estilo
la manera de bailar pero sobre todo nos
gustaba mucho la música nos pasamos
horas de horas
ensayando alejándonos de nuestro círculo
convencional enfocados en hacer música
en hacer arte
fue así que todo se fue identificando
obviamente en el ínterin de adentrarnos
más en la movida musical de nuestra
ciudad también sentimos el deseo de
hacer cosas no tan productivas como
los desvelos las copas hasta el amanecer
y una serie más de cosas que no eran
productivas pero nos dimos cuenta que si
queríamos llegar a cumplir nuestros
sueños debíamos ser disciplinados
y refugiar nos en la composición de
canciones fue uno de esos buenos hábitos
ya que cuando tú compones una ocasión
puedes expresar el sentimiento sea
positivo o negativo y plasmarlo
transmitirlo
por ejemplo así fue como compuse la
primera el primer single de la banda la
letra huracán si lo escucharon
james
[Música]
esta canción la compuse en un momento en
el que me encontraba frustrado por
varios aspectos personales como el amor
los estudios la banda también y otras
barreras más que en ese momento estaban
en mi camino entonces la idea de esta
canción se basó en que no importa que es
que estés pasando que barreras estén en
tu camino lo importante siempre va a ser
resurgir
levantarte y volver a intentarlo
resurgir levantarte y intentarlo
en nuestros primeros años de banda
conocimos personas muy increíbles
construimos fuertes amistades
pero también pasamos por experiencias
muy desagradables totalmente
cuál fue el motivo de estas experiencias
desagradables aquí se debió ahora según
mi experiencia y la trayectoria que
tenemos creo que se debieron a no saber
manejar dos principios fundamentales
el primer principio
es el equilibrio el equilibrio del amor
amarte a ti mismo ya los que te rodean
es una frase bien repetida pero el
equilibrio que existe entre el amor
propio y el que damos a los demás
determina nuestro éxito o fracaso
principalmente nuestro bienestar
caminando hacia nuestros objetivos
como sabemos muy bien la mayor parte de
las cosas deben tener un equilibrio
cuando damos demasiado demasiado amor a
alguien y no recibimos la misma
intensidad de ese sentimiento dado esto
puede llegar a bajonearnos mucho o
deprimirnos en el peor en el peor de los
casos por otro lado cuando tenemos un
sobreexceso grado de amor propio podemos
llegar a enceguecernos y no darnos
cuenta del daño que podemos ocasionar a
las personas que nos rodean en nuestro
caminar
fue a partir de este pensamiento que
empecé a analizar más mis actitudes
ya nutrir me también más no quiero que
vean un vídeo de una caída que tuve en
en medio de un show
estamos en cochabamba
[Música]
la que ya pudo haber sido como esas las
que temperaturas un hueso y
es terminal
y también hubieron más ángulos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y ahora mi gente que baila lo que me
caigo pero
a comienzos me sentí muy muy avergonzado
porque fue bien chistoso pero también me
sentí muy importante por las personas
que me escribieron para preguntarme cómo
estaba entre ellas mi mamá que me dijo
'está daniel que tienes que hacerte unos
exámenes que no te estás cuidando
y tiene razón no me estaba cuidando lo
suficiente creo que es importante pensar
en nosotros en nutrirnos de amor
nutrirnos de amor nos da méritos en tres
aspectos fundamentales la parte teórica
viene aquí
en primer lugar en el aspecto físico
bueno teniendo una buena salud haciendo
ejercicios en el aspecto psicológico
tenemos una actitud positiva al momento
de realizar las actividades que
conllevan
y por último el aspecto espiritual creo
que teniendo el hábito automático de
trazar nos nuevas metas de proyectarnos
[Música]
y fue así que empezamos que empecé a
trabajar más el amor en mi vida creo que
es muy importante que nos nutramos de
amor todos
y bueno quiero pasar ahora al segundo
principio
este es crear un ambiente positivo
al no crear un ambiente positivo con las
personas que te rodean cualquier suceso
puede emprender ese camino de pólvora
que da como resultado explotar contra
todo y por todo contra todo en nuestros
primeros conciertos la falta de
conocimiento en este aspecto nos llevó a
amargas experiencias con el público
incluso a faltarnos el respeto y
confrontarnos entre nosotros mismos
hubo una ocasión en la que tocábamos en
un local
y el ambiente estaba un poco tenso
habían problemas personales no creo que
no habíamos tenido una buena prueba de
sonido y otra serie de cosas más y justo
en la última canción un señor se subió a
querer arrancarme y posteriormente
pegarme porque no deje que su hijo cante
esta última canción con nosotros a pesar
de que él me lo había pedido en
repetidas ocasiones en medio del show
bueno estaba negativo y como todo
explotó en caos era puñetas por acá por
acá mi hermano se salió y
pero no todo un problema creo que fueron
experiencias bastante oscuras temporadas
oscuras pero que de cierta manera
agradezco que hayan sucedido porque nos
enseñaron el valor de dos grandes
palabras que siempre han sido capaces de
cambiar nuestra actitud
somos familia
estas dos palabras son clave considero
que son clave al momento de iniciar
cualquier proyecto
debo recalcar que en familia
va más allá de las personas que
comparten tu sangre el término según la
rae la real academia española lo define
como grupo de personas enfrentadas entre
sí que viven juntas ahora aquí nos
hacemos otra pregunta qué significa el
término emparentar
también la red lo define como adquirir
relación de afinidad o semejanza con
otra entonces familia quiere decir grupo
de personas que tienen una relación de
afinidad que comparten o viven juntas
[Música]
en este sentido creo que construir una
buena relación entre bandas siempre
soluciono muchos muchos conflictos
por ejemplo me ayudó a darme cuenta de
muchas de mis actitudes muy inapropiadas
como llamarle la atención a alguien en
público
o hacer énfasis de los errores de
alguien en reuniones que no tenía mucho
que ver
por último bromear con alguien que haya
tenido un mal día y creo que el poder
sentarme a hablar con cada integrante en
paz y con la cabeza fría siempre se
solucionó muchos problemas
por ejemplo también hubieron ocasiones
en la que mi falta de empatía y
liderazgo nos llevaron a peleas a
provocar incluso golpes que
pudo haber separarnos tendencias
separarnos mejor dicho
en una ocasión tocábamos en un local
también
un integrante de la banda llegó muy
tarde
y yo al ver lo que se armaba muy lenta y
desanimada mente para empezar a tocar
fui a reclamarle con un tono negativo
que se apure y él le agarró y me dijo
bueno no toco estos instrumentos
me voy yo
y él
él me dijo mira no tenía buen día
uno de mis hijos
y lo llevamos al hospital
todas las maneras
[Música]
y balísticas
pero también pasa otra situación con
otro integrante otro integrante de la
banda perdón creo que ese micrófono no
señora
[Música]
también pasa otra situación con otro
integrante que justo al terminar de
reclamarle todo lo mal que pensaba de él
todo lo mal que estaba haciéndolo lo
peor el solo me dijo mira
y te pido perdón viejo
mi abuelita falleció
y voy a cambiar
[Música]
ya ese momento me sentí muy mal como
ahora sin saber qué hacer y bueno
[Música]
estás como otras situaciones creo que me
enseñaron que la práctica de la empatía
aplicada al momento indicado nos ayuda a
actuar de la manera correcta
creo que la empatía es la característica
fundamental de un líder y nos ayuda a
crear un ambiente positivo
creo que todos nuestros logros se han
debido a la unión y la empatía que hemos
logrado formar a medida de este tiempo y
creo que se va a ver reflejado mucho más
de acuerdo cuanto nos íbamos a conciliar
como familia
en síntesis y para finalizar esta
pequeña charla
en este camino existen muchas barreras
pero
sobre todo mucho aprendizaje de por
medio
[Música]
así como muchas más personas con
objetivos con metas
porque silencio no así como muchas más
personas con objetivos y metas trazadas
yo intento diariamente llegar a la cima
y en el proceso me equivoco digo cosas
que no debo decir y comentó realmente
demasiados errores
infinidad
y en la aventura de llegar hasta donde
ahora me encuentro he sentido mucho
miedo
tristeza e incertidumbre pero también
mucha fe valor y seguridad lo que hago
creo que desde el momento que empecé a
hacer como que un plan para dedicarle
total tiempo a mi pasión empezaron a
multiplicarse las actividades hasta
llegar a la época de ahora que sigo
cumpliendo más tareas
cuando tenemos la capacidad de
visualizar nuestro futuro cambiamos
nuestro destino
desde que inicia este camino siempre se
hicieron un montón de oportunidades para
renunciar a veces nuestros amigos la
familia nos desaniman pero creo que
nosotros somos los principales
que cortamos esa motivación
por pensamientos negativos
cuando instalamos vision en nuestra vida
empiezan a venir los recursos para
cumplir nuestro objetivo
no existe un manual para el éxito
señoras y señores considero que
el éxito está en la dedicación sin
importar que el avance sea lento o
rápido
todos mis logros
se los llevó el amor muchas gracias
[Aplausos]